I reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm
John Humphrey apparently this Toy Story
for teaser trailer dropped had no idea I
think we're the first ones to get it up
is that exciting before we hop into this
I wanted to plug ourselves we're on the
start us at people over there we do
30-second reactions for films TV shows
and trailers we post practically daily
over there sometimes twice a day
watch it download the app it's free to
use free to download do it today use our
lengthy you see right here alright let's
go back to infinity and beyond shall we
[Music]
a second answer does guessing Netflix
[Music]
what
Oh No
[Music]
it's a symbolism anything [ __ ]
[Music]
Wow
that's what everyone was requesting I
feel like I just saw the whole movie
this I know man talk about trailers give
it away too much at once
jeepers Christ all those characters are
returning who'd have thought you know I
gotta admit though you know I was on the
camp like I really need a toy store
before I thought it ended perfectly
seeing this I was like no screw it
I'm happy to see them that's you I'm a
little worried that we're maybe gonna
fly too close to the Sun after such a
crisp trilogy as the Toy Story ya bin
but great thing about Toy Story is you
know those toys will always be the same
yeah you know they live inside computers
I'm excited for this new characters like
a homemade toy or cute yeah and I wonder
what that's supposed to say about the
movie I can't tell if this this is just
some funny cute teaser sure because the
Toy Story films have always done that
haven't liked great teaser trailers
something that's not in the actual movie
just designed for the trailer format and
like all rejoicing maybe they haven't
you owner you know they're all having
that together but the digs are gonna
fall apart I don't know if it's actually
doing that or something cute either way
I'm excited they're back the toys are
back in town
the toys are back in town hey the spore
character it's gonna be a huge thing oh
yeah big deal man so many Disney is
literally going to be selling sporks
like with this glued on pipe cleaners
for like 30 bucks pop and if it's
anything like the last couple toy
stories it's a villain that's what we
know yeah it's gonna evil
start out being somebody who's like
reassuring and like ready to help the
toy really he just wants to maintain
don't feel like I was watching a Super
Smash Brothers tray yeah lately does
everyone be teaming up and I mean Toy
Story they were already a team nowadays
he had just feels like Oh everyone's
here I couldn't tell if the toys that
all died and ascended into heaven yeah
that's gonna be the real twist of this
movie is they're going to all realize
the end it's gonna be like one massive
success
we're all dead we're all dead living in
these toys we actually know it's good
yeah they're gonna retcon Toy Story 3
and it's gonna turn out that they
actually got melted to death in the
garbage this is where they wound up is
in heaven with oh this is really fun
thanks for requesting this was plenty to
go off of here ton I could see why you
wanted us to do a you know review for
this we could name every character Jack
spinner D Ward trailer reaction or he's
doing that in fact every time I name
somebody during a trailer now I think
about that hey before we wrap this up I
want to give a patient the day shout-out
to a man named totally jumbled totally
jumbled you know that I'm constantly you
know making jokes about the fact that
you have a new baby and you got to keep
your marriage alive but listen I wanted
to give you some real advice this time
all right what you got to do is in your
relationship have someone get buzzed
maybe give her a little bit of mr.
Potato Head you know have a good time
with some woody action you want to make
sure you don't drink too much so you're
not slinky and Rex is a character king
of the bedroom much like Rex is king of
the dinosaurs and whatnot okay I hope
you're doing well buddy
love you I thought of that on the car
ride over here you guys can subscribe to
rejects Ted not to obvious all right
look that notification bell and you know
download and false and start us up yay
you